a steady stream of people signing the
book of condolences in henley on thames
the people who live in this
quintessentially english town would hold
the queen and the royal family close to
their hearts
the regular mid-afternoon mass took on a
different feel in many ways this became
one of the first memorial services to
queen elizabeth ii
the news of the queen's passing
genuinely seems to have come as quite a
shock to many here
it's something the clergy had
anticipated and believed that in the
coming days they will be called upon to
give support and guidance
i think that people will probably be
almost slightly taken by surprise it's a
thing that i often say when people live
very long that although you feel that it
shouldn't be a shock
and that everybody would have expected
it actually the fact that they've lived
so long you start to feel almost like
that the person is kind of eternal like
like the kind of rocks under our
feet and in a way it actually makes it
more difficult and so i think that
people will be taken by surprise
henley is a sleepy place for sure but
there was something different a sort of
sense of loss people not quite sure what
to do with themselves
we heard that she was resting which we'd
heard before and um
one presumed uh eventually she'd be all
right and then you suddenly heard she
died and
was quite shocked
the length and breadth of the uk people
have their own memories and their own
stories about the queen i had the
privilege to work
for her majesty with angela kelly on a
book
for the diamond jubilee
bernard connolly collaborated on a book
celebrating the queen's coronation he
ended up working for her for three years
like so many others she changed his life
she was very
humble
and very kind
and just
a very patient woman actually i found
and a
naughty sense of humor
[Music]
the queen has passed and we now have a
king and that is how it works a
centuries-old tradition that ensures we
always have a figurehead
it means that nothing has changed
although of course in reality everything
has changed
mr ramsey sky news henley on thames
[Music]